[Musique]
on
j
je
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on a perdu tout on n'a pas du tout les
assets matériel la maison et 1er août a
perdu même le matériel de plage on a
tout perdu en arrière mais n'en n'ont
pas de l'argent lorsque six toiles à ce
qu'ils ne soient pas privés y dormir
ailleurs ce que tu as pensé pendant des
années au bout de deux jours ça
s'écroule
[Musique]
non
ap relativement entre les deux les deux
sites
on est à brest 1200 qui sont là oui on
est
sur la pluie a pas de page est encore
beaucoup plus de listes parce que les
maisons
qui sont pas écoulés en train d'être
prises
[Musique]
compte tenu de l'ampleur du sinistre et
du contexte particulièrement difficile
que connaît le pays
le gouvernement par ma voix sous
l'autorité du père à la république chef
de l'état déclare le pays en situation
de catastrophe et lance un appel à
solidarité nationale et internationale
[Musique]
non